4 من القانون الجنائي الروسي
الاتحاد على حقيقة 19
سبتمبر النقل البري
الحوادث في منطقة الصورة
المنطقة التي مات فيها 50 صيفًا
هرب سائق المشاة من مكان الحادث
خلال الأحداث المشتركة للموظفين
قسم المباحث الجنائية
أصلي المجموعة د الزملاء وأنا
مياه النهر ليست في صور المقاطعات ولكن
أيضا مفتشي عيون من شرطة المرور
درست كاميرات الدوائر التلفزيونية المغلقة
أجرى مجمع بحث تشغيلي في
التي تم تحديد سيارة لادا داخلها
بريورا طابعة النقل البري
مزيد من الحوادث من قبل النشطاء
تم تثبيته من قبل السائقين بعد تفكيك حادث
جزء السيارة الذي تم حفره عليه
واحدة من المؤامرات فارغة من القطاع الخاص
منازل في القرية التي تعيش فيها
قطع من قبل الشرطة
كما دمرت السيارة بشكل جزئي و
لوحة تسجيل الدولة
وجدت السيارة و
ضبطت المشتبه به الآن
غانا هو مقياس للإكراه الإجرائي في
يتم تنفيذ شكل الالتزام بالظهور
مزيد من العمل الطبيعي
تهدف إلى إنشاء كل شيء
ظروف المرور
الحوادث